どこだっけなぁある中でとも脱ドンキとか行くんですけどその時たまたま見つけたん
ですよ
あったこれだ今回見つけたのはこちらです何が入ってるかわからない良いものが出るか
もしれないし出ないかもしれない今回はこちら童貞飼い方でございます想定がいいか
ちゃ俺が来た一高いですよ
今まで回ってきたら謎のがチャット下
砂を持ったガチャっていうちょっとねもうね喜多院
がないもう切ってる事すらも許されないような名前のガチャなんですねここで想定回
ガチャで本
エイドが出るかもしれないって書いてあるからいいのが出るかもしれない
すぎ当たり前の事をあなたがもうカッコよく言ってみましたはじめ社長ですどんどん
言っていた想定外方を全部買ってきました
[音楽]
mar
jr ん
ます
[音楽]
今回はすごいよそして中身はまず見てないを持つわかんなかった皆さんお店よかった
よかった
こちらにあるとか想定解決の中身です
[音楽]
あー見ないようにして19個10曲ありました
何が出るかもしれないグッズ物シリーズ今回はさあすぐにヤバイのでしょ+ゲージ
そろそろねなんかこう3 d s 駅開眼未来なってる出てもいいのではないかと思い
ますでは見ていきましょう
これは見ていきますを1個目ですお腹に見えてるじゃあ完全にこれは完全に妖怪メダル
ですね
1個目はこちら
妖怪メダルで見るか田村次頼むんその客演以上の価値があればそれぞれにいい気がする
はぁっ
あ菟田野区布田6札のプリ歌ダークエイジたーーーこれうたのプリンスさまの話がドリ
フェスだ
全然わかんない間伐ならこれははいっ
[音楽]
俺これ5ショットセラ黒い自由と区の三田て喜ぶ奴なのかもしれないが僕は黒い習得の
ファンではございません次へはいこれ
ギリギリまで悩みたくないところではだ妖怪メダリア
何なのよだめなら待ってるの次これは期待なら大きいと
year
うなんだでこれはちょっとこういうのはでなぜ誰か管のダレトク
誰得なにこれえ待ってコレなになになになにこれ何伝説の刀カタナのあの部分ですね
奇跡的に方が守っていれば
アーカン店どこの部分ですこの部分のガチャですまず誰特大本当にも彼のこれ誰得なの
豊臣秀吉
が豊臣秀吉の奴ら
すべて
あなたが良かったわー今んとこ何をピンと来てないそうそう何かちょっと僕がちょっと
おおってなるような奴が出て欲しいんですけど
片桐伊月くん
たまにすぎや金谷つ選んだけど開いたあー
4回目だもうちょっと待って妖怪メダル技術が高いぞ今回
何度すっげーなに妖怪メダルがすごい出るところそういうやっすいやつはこれいます
ファイター
はいおっおおっこれ新しいぞ g のレコンギスタガンダムですね
ガンダムの人が入っている秘境マテマテマテ茶熊ねまたよねこれ絶対主人公
敵キャラではないでしょこいつと隣にいるって事はもうそれなりのそれでしょたぶん次
はい vaxpot ああっ ok えんちゃん今回今回はいい気がするぞはい
うほほー
完全にふざけてですよねえばって待って待って待って
やっぱ詰まってエバジャムがこんな方々の説明書みたいなやつ400円もすんの
えっ超特山でも売れ登ってたってこといやちょっと結果も見れてくださいこう言える
ゴルゴがいるわけなんですけども叩かのゴルゴいないんですよ
つまりシェイクレットこの整形た方もこいつだったということです
猫
すごくないあったかって400円もするんでしょっていう意味でゴルゴの方の
シークレット勝てましたこれはかなりいいんじゃないですか
アタリはいずっとにこれ方へなんだこれは3ジャックまあこれかな
qs の台ですね k2の大ジャンはかわいいで次
今でも多分ゴルゴぐらいですからなんかこうグッときたのがない
ドリフェスの及川しんくんです3人目
コンプリードが使いですねつぎ1本うぇいおっぱデューラー立てながら座はこれを得見
てたんだよアニメが見てたアニメのが出ると嬉しいですね可愛いな
でララのあれです暴力的で強い人ですね肺がん男性のレコンギスタさん中身は果たして
ハイパーでもなんか主人公かな
あれこれ主人公札あ主人公ダーツ子
方が出たいやどんどん行きましょうそう
はチン撃の巨人ジャンジャンが当たりました
でもね他のキャラを見るとねもっと欲しいのがたくさんいますね
ミカサが欲しかったところですツイ廃ば g のレコンギスタの人恋
ん悪くないんだ you
こっち派残り少ない中で一家にあたりを引きつけるか今回のポイントですな
はい
頬ワープぞやっとはいもクロ
めっちゃかわいいやも苦労は完全にあたりでしょ
ひょっとやってるとラインナップを見てもまあ今御三家が当たりと言っても過言では
ないなぁの飛ぶもありだったがや肝臓えっを
うれしい
ac ほど嬉しい食わないんですけどだけどこのラインナップの中で見ると多分
めちゃくちゃあたりの方ではないでしょう勘九郎は一番うれしいねありがとうござい
ます次客演でポケモンのキーホルダー当たるのかなりでかいねそれをご苦労とかいう
人気ポツンとはい
次はいワークと絶対妖怪メダルだったでも
ジバニャンですこれはいいのかなわかんないなぁクラフト2つとなりました骨から出て
いきましょう小さい方からさあこいなんだ
んルーラーの人だはい汲み出しライダーの人ですねっに見てると嬉しいにょ揺らすと一
つあってしまいました
この中にもう全てを託すだけで今回はれと当たりが多かった気がするんですけどそんな
ねなんか今回を嫌な気持ちではしてないです
ジャラスティックいきますはーい
中身はこちらではいこのシューズとは甲このイベントはまさか
か
it を受けていかがだったでしょうかいう爽快かつあの多分ありと
悪くはなかった気がしますハズレなのはハズレだよってもひょっとしたらこの売り
フェスも了解ウォッチも好きな人からしたらすごいうれしいとかも知ればそれ以外は
そんなで悪くもなかっ
んポケモンの黒子入ったのかすごいてくださったと思いますアートことシークレットの
カタカナあなたもねただ行って5
思うんですけど
[音楽]
やめておけばよかったん
me
あっ